yes ashrita swaron with just a crushing
dominant win in her game 26 moves just
what the doctor ordered asharita you
played this game
quietly at first but then she just went
after you with e5 f5 was the real one
and you decided okay no more monkey
business d4 and winford what promoted
that kind of aggression in your mind um
honestly i wasn't prepared for what she
played because this is not something she
normally does with g6 she usually plays
c65 so i was on my own from move two
basically um and so when she played this
e5 uh f5 it felt wrong because she
didn't develop her queen side and so i
decided you know d4 i actually
initially missed this pawn sacrifice i
mean when i played d4 that she can just
take on e495 bishop e5 take and queen f6
but then after i thought about it um
i was like i have the two bishops and
the dark squares around the king are
just weak and she's underdeveloped so i
was like a pawn doesn't really feel like
that much um and so i played king h1
queen f6 and also i was up on the clock
by quite a bit so that helped a lot too
and then here i thought she could go
bishop g4
um to pin my knight and i was looking at
like bishop g5
uh queen takes g5
knight g5 bishop d1 rookie seven
um and i'm still a pawn down but this
end game felt a little bit better
because of the active pieces but i
thought
here
yeah i thought this was better for me
but the way she played it she let me
keep i think the dark square bishop um
and i think with her low time it just
seemed like i had a lot of initiative
especially with c4 opening the position
up
well we don't need to explain anything
else after that
that was a master class and explanation
and then you played c4
uh just blasting open the game even more
what prompted this move
uh
honestly i thought like i wanted my
i wanted to keep my bishop on e5 alive i
thought if i let her like say if i don't
do anything maybe she can go knight d7
and target my bishop and so i just
played c4 knight d7 half bishop c3 to
keep my bishop alive i didn't really
care about giving up my second pawn
because her king is weak and two bishops
in open position and again her pieces on
the queen center not developed fully yet
so i thought c4 d take c4
um
i think d takes c4
i wasn't entirely sure what i was
planning but maybe queen c3 or something
or rogue d1
it just felt right to me and then when
she played bishop e6
um i saw that i was thinking of queen b4
but then i thought maybe it would be
better to have the knight on e7 to
attack it as well when i go queen before
so i played g4
i thought i was thinking maybe she can
go knight g7 but it looked a little
scary already
that's a fianchetto knight that nobody
wants to have like queen b4 and then
this
final blunder of hers as she took your
pawn and you played bishop d6 a great
moment and her position is in full state
of cardiac arrest and b6 and you pick
off a piece
brilliant game well explained crushing
attack you're in first place by yourself
at the moment what does that feel like
uh it doesn't feel like much there's
still five more games and i think i have
my toughest opponents in the last five
games irina and karissa still left so
i'm just taking it one game at a time
glad i could win with the white pieces
today
you said that you want to win this
tournament you made that flag stick that
flag your thoughts are still the same my
thoughts are still the same i was very
lucky yesterday so i'm thankful i didn't
lose yesterday and looking forward to
keeping the melantoma all right
congratulations keep it up thank you
sharitha just a quick question first of
all congratulations very very well done
is this your best position that you've
had at this stage of a u.s championships
that you've competed in definitely i
think in the past four years i've always
had a rough start like i think
especially last year started half out of
three and then i somehow picked up like
two wins every three games so and this
is also also the first time where i've
had a lot of draws usually i have a lot
of wins and losses because i go for
decisive play
but yeah this is definitely the first
time i've had such a good start
keep it up good luck
wow nice